welcome back to the stronger buy science
podcast
in today's episode we've got a huge
update related to the good news segment
some very impressive and potentially
controversial feats of strength
and dueling research reviews about fish
oil and distinguishing between
responders and non-responders to
training
we also answer some listener questions
then we congratulate the sport of
baseball for becoming interesting again
as always thank you for listening and
enjoy the show
[Music]
welcome back to the stronger by science
podcast this is your host eric trexler
today i am joined
by a special temporary guest co-host his
name is greg knuckles greg how you doing
i am doing well how are you i am doing
well
i do have some news for the listeners
this news might be hard
to hear but the good news segment is
suspended indefinitely
you can only have so many segments about
animals being happy uh yeah the good
news segment is cancelled
uh because i was just reaching for any
animal story i could find and greg
you were just you were really uh trying
to destroy the good news segment
from within uh you you turned it into
the
neutral but usually bad news segment as
much as you could
no no i made it the good news segment as
much as i could
i found stories that had
it's it's less like every cloud has a
silver lining and more like in the good
news game
every silver cloud has a dark lining and
i looked for the ones with the smallest
dark lining but
i couldn't leave those dark linings
unremarked upon
fair enough but the good news is that
we're not just simply abandoning the
good news segment
um we are replacing it in recent
episodes you probably heard
uh greg's sub segment called road to the
stage
we're gonna bring that front and center
really shine a spotlight on that
uh so greg road to the stage what are
the updates for us
uh yeah so uh hit a new low in the last
two weeks which is nice
uh i think when last we talked i'd hit
like 248.6 give or take
uh i hit a new low of 247.
and my trend weight is now solidly below
250
so uh you know good good objective
markers of progress all around
and this week my rate of weight loss
actually trended down so
losing at a slower rate than previously
but
uh there there is actually a silver
lining in that
um so one of the
one of the things that i think i've done
poorly when trying to lose weight before
is be able to accept good enough
so basically uh if i would deviate from
what i was trying to eat
i just kind of say like ah [ __ ] it throw
my hands up today
uh you know i went off script
try to do better tomorrow um
and i think if if i'd get like two or
three of those days in a week
uh it would completely mitigate
the entire caloric deficit i'd opened up
on the rest of the days of the week so
this past week hasn't been particularly
great and you know
just didn't have as much time to meal
prep a lot of stuff going on
but my small win that i'm pretty proud
of is
even when the dietary situations were
less than ideal
i was still good about even if i wasn't
hitting
the magnitude of calorie deficit that i
needed to to continue losing weight at
the rate that i wanted to
i still ate below my maintenance
calories every day
you know so basically instead of uh
a complete win still like small wins
small progress better than no progress
uh and so that that's something i've
struggled with before
uh and that is a skill i think i'm
developing and improving on so
uh you know momentum slowing down is
better than
losing all momentum and reversing
momentum and so i think
you know i'm i'm doing better at
stopping the bleeding
than than i've done previously that's
awesome
and you know in coaching i've had i've
had clients where
you know it can be challenging to deal
with the slowing of momentum
and in some cases working with clients
if the you know if the weight loss goal
is really ambitious and it's pursued
over a really long time
you might run into situations where
weight loss has
really slowed to a halt but not yet
gone the other direction right we're not
regaining weight yet
and so a lot of times i'll have clients
who are in that position and they'll say
oh man this is terrible i'm not making
progress
we're failing here and i'm like let's
let's look back at the weight trajectory
and
you know let's consider the fact that
we're now maintaining
a body weight that's 40 pounds lighter
than we started you know and we're not
moving the other direction so like
call it a diet break if you want but we
are the
fact that we're maintaining here and not
going the other direction is a win
you know so it's always important to
remind yourself of that or remind your
clients of that
is when they get to that point where
there's some friction in the process
it's hard to make that same
rate of progress or you know things have
really stalled out
you know it's important to remember that
maintaining a huge success is still
successful you know and and hopefully
you can get the ball rolling again
when the time is right for that
sometimes you need a little break
sometimes you can
dive right into it but but no that
that's really fantastic
now i'm not on a road to the stage
been there done that you know competed
at the absolute
highest level um you know went as far as
any person could ever hope to go
in multiple sports on the stage and
now i'm on to something bigger not to
put down your goals that would be rude
but
[Laughter]
i'm on the road to enlightenment um so
during covid i got pretty into secular
buddhism
and because we're so sarcastic all the
time people are gonna think i'm being
disingenuous here
or being sarcastic i'm not and if you
want to know how serious i
am about this um let me put it this way
i have read three and a half books since
i got into this
greg you've known me for a long time i
don't read i can but i choose not to
if i'm actually reading books i mean
this is an unprecedented level of
interest
i've never read books about anything
unless forced
so i'm super into it i'm on the road to
enlightenment
becoming more mindful it's something
that i
certainly need as we've discussed on the
podcast previously
um my natural
kind of my natural
pattern of cognition that has been
conditioned and cultivated
and practiced time and time again
leads generally straight to anxiety or
pessimism
like those are the two roads when when i
have any kind of thought
those are just the really grooved
patterns that my thought process you
know kind of follows
so uh i very much need this road to
enlightenment
uh and it is the hardest thing i've ever
tried to do
trying to recondition the way i think
and the way i
respond to things uh cognitively and
emotionally
it is the hardest thing i've ever tried
and i've always been drawn to
activities that reward discipline you
know like in high school as a wrestler
i'm
you know not that i condone it sitting
in the sauna i haven't had a drink of
water in
hours not going to drink water for many
more hours like
you know pushing against the the most
basic urges a human body has like
oh yeah me versus thirst that's a fun
challenge uh bodybuilding me versus
hunger
and not being able to sleep for a few
months very cool challenge
none of that was as hard as trying to
kind of recondition your mind
out of what feels to be the natural
inclination so i'm on the road to
enlightenment and it is
uh it's challenging but i'm working on
it uh so i'll be providing updates but
that also means that unfortunately
uh i'm leaning into this hard so i'm
getting into the secular buddhism
uh a lot of people who are into buddhism
don't eat meat
uh and so for the time being i am not
eating any meat
so the shredded chicken recipes are
suspended indefinitely
so greg you're gonna have to come up
with some macro-friendly shredded
chicken
lasagna type dishes uh they're not going
to be coming from me for a while
and i've also you know people have come
to love the
really indulgent
culinary things i've put together and
i'm abandoning that as well because i
just realized
i'm going so over the top uh in the
kitchen
chasing these kind of sensory pleasures
you know trying to
make a meal more hedonically pleasing
than the previous and i realized that
i mean it's so over the top with the
flavor profiles that i'm putting
together with all these
ingredient combinations and all of it is
to chase this fleeting
sensory experience that's not real you
know so
uh i'm trying to enjoy the simpler
things in life and really just kind of
appreciating the ingredients for what
they are you know so i'm not getting
into these
really complex flavor combinations i'm
keeping it simple
rice and beans is like my main meal
these days so
greg we're going to have to lean on you
for a lot more of that nutrition
or i should say cooking content i'm
still coming with the nutrition content
but the cooking
is just it's just not a priority right
now fair enough
fair enough okay uh what about feats of
strength
uh yeah so there there are actually
quite a few this time around
uh between world's strongest man
olympic trials uh
powerlifting usapl nationals was was uh
i think last weekend so yeah there there
have been a lot of strong things that
have happened recently so
first off i'm going to give you a small
spoiler alert
if you typically watch world's strongest
man
when it airs on television which i think
will be in a few months
if you want to be surprised at who wins
just
skip forward a couple minutes uh but
okay you've been warned tom stoltman uh
congratulations on the world's strongest
man win
uh he had a uh
tight battle with brian shaw brian shaw
i think was going for his
fourth or fifth win uh at world's
strongest man but tom stoltman
took it home uh this was his first win
and congratulations to him he
i here did really well uh i was unable
to watch it seeing as it hasn't been
televised yet but
i saw the score sheet so congratulations
to tom
uh quick question before we move away
from strongman um
i noticed that thor obviously you know
didn't compete he retired
from strongman competition um
i don't know it's weird because we
bumped into thor
in iceland we went to his gym uh super
friendly
had a great time there he was very
gracious with his time
uh you know kind of he was busy and
still made time for us to chat and hang
out
um i'll just cut
straight to it i'm not going to beat
around the bush do you believe that thor
retired
because of how we out angled him when we
took pictures with him
do you think he was so emasculated by
the way we out angled him that he
couldn't
couldn't get it together for another
competition
uh you maybe
maybe when you out-angled him yeah
i have to admit that i i did not
see it was in fact you out angled me
pretty hard
in a couple photos on that trip
including the one
that i've tried to keep off the internet
and definitely haven't shared on
instagram a few times for the memes
uh the one that indicates that i am five
foot one
correct yeah i just i wish he would have
talked to me before he retired though
because it's just the coat i was wearing
was really bulky i mean it was cold in
iceland
uh so i didn't i didn't mean to to go
that hard
and i wish that he would have just
talked to me before making this rash
decision but anyway go on
yeah yeah so uh next feat of strength uh
this is more a feat of power but we'll
let it slide
we've talked about uh shot put throwers
on the podcast before doing strong
things in the gym
uh i'm blanking on his first name last
name kovacs though american thrower
uh jim monster he's done some
some crazy dead lifting i know we've
talked about him on the podcast
uh but now we're actually going to talk
about shot put
ryan krauser at the olympic trials
broke the world record for the shot put
which
just to contextualize that the previous
record by randy barnes had stood since
1991.
[Music]
i know we've talked about this general
concept as it relates to throwing but
in most sports you just think like ah
you know training methods are improving
new athletes in the sport records are
falling all the time
that really hasn't been the case in
throwing the mail shot put world record
had stood since 1991
i think the female record uh is still
standing and has stood since either 88
or 87.
uh those were some very durable world
records
which roughly coincided with when
wada started drug testing you can uh
it's a weird coincidence yeah you can
you can draw whatever
inferences from that you want uh but
ryan krauser finally broke through
and didn't just beat randy barnes world
record he destroyed it he beat it by
like eight nine inches which is uh
just a complete ass whooping in shot put
so it is hard to overstate how momentous
of a throw that was
so huge congratulations to him
all right now moving into our bread and
butter it's powerlifting time
like i said usapl nationals happened
recently
and the talk of the town uh was
absolutely taylor atwood and for good
reason he
totaled uh 18 48 and a half
in freedom units or 838 and a half
in kilograms in the 163 or 74 kilogram
weight class
uh which is bonkers
so uh he already held that world record
he broke his own record
broke it by a lot uh and
almost one like he almost totaled
more he almost totaled enough to have
won the 83 class as well
and the world record was broken in the
83 class also
uh just to just to put in context how
wild his total was
um it is i think
the first 600
uh wilkes drug tested ever uh it's a
it's a wilkes of 605 that broke uh
andre's stenazic's record that had stood
since 2002
um and also so
usapl nationals no knee wraps uh
strictly drug tested under those
conditions
taylor atwood also broke the untested
with knee wraps world record total at
165
so you know just a
absolutely incredible performance by him
uh also shout outs to heather connor
she totaled 899 and a half pounds or 408
kilos
in the 103 pound 47 kilo weight class
uh and that broke uh chin wei ling's
record that had stood since uh 2015
and you know i'm sure this doesn't
matter anywhere outside of the u.s
but very very close to breaking the 900
pound
barrier which uh i mean that's that's a
big total
at 103 pounds so a huge congratulations
to her
and then so the the next ones i'm going
to throw out there
aren't records but just shout outs to
uh people i know in real life who broke
some big
barriers that they've been aiming for
for a long time
bryce lewis broke the two thousand pound
barrier in
in the total in the 105 kilo weight
class 231 pound weight class
uh he's been really close to that for a
few years so
uh great to see him break through and
jamar royster
broke the 700 pound squat barrier in the
183 class
so huge congratulations to him as well
and then moving into the world of
equipped powerlifting jimmy
i don't know if you pronounce his name
colb or cobb
i i think it's colb but there was a
football
player with the same last name that was
pronounced cobb and he played for the
jets or the eagles one of the two one of
the green teams
i think there's a county in georgia
that's spelled like that and pronounced
cobb yeah so jimmy kolb or cobb
one of the two uh hit probably the most
impressive
equipped bench press that i've ever seen
uh he benched uh 1120 pounds in single
ply
which i don't know all of the details
of improvements in bench shirt
technology that have occurred in the
last couple of decades
but my understanding is that the single
ply equipment on the market now
is basically the same as the single ply
equipment that was on the market a
decade ago
but there have been some pretty huge
uh improvements in the unlimited
category of gear like there's a new kind
of bench shirt that's not even allowed
in multiply meets like it's
different i i think it adds like more
elastic stuff
into the mix i don't know all the
details but apparently there's
way way better unlimited
style bench shirts on the market now
uh and uh jimmy cobb's
single ply bench press record beats all
of those so
so it's the heaviest equipped bench
press ever performed
uh and i mean the the video will be
linked you can watch it
it's pretty clean too uh there are
there have been you know over the last
15 years
a lot of equip bench press world records
with really really soft elbows at
lockout but
he controls it well pretty solid lockout
uh
by by equipped lifting standards very
very solid bench so
huge props to him uh and then the final
feat of strength
i'm not sure what i think about it but
it's a provisional feat of strength i
guess
yeah uh so on the stronger by science
podcast we believe
in teaching the controversy in all
things
and that includes huge bench presses
from people who haven't necessarily
proved that they're good for it in
competition
so an iranian venture named
daniel zamani i believe uh
benched 337 and a half kilos or
744 pounds in the gym
and he made he made it look like
most strong people would binge 315. like
he
blew it up and that's 315 pounds
it did not look challenging at all
and the reason i say i'm not totally
sold on it
is so i
have sympathy for him empathy for him
because he's iranian
and you know visa issues it's hard to
travel to compete
so he hasn't competed recently um
but the last meet where he posted
a total um or well posted a successful
bench attempt was a single ply meet
and he benched 760 in single ply then uh
several years ago like five or six years
ago is when he did his last raw meat
which was a drug tested meat
and he benched 747 there so
has he wait 7 47 raw or
474. okay sorry sorry yeah it's like
slightly like what is happening yeah
yeah slight dyslexic moment
474. uh yeah yeah so
has he seen ridiculous progress
over the last two years i don't know uh
it would it would border on being
unprecedented
but it's possible uh again
you can watch the video you can see for
yourself he's a big [ __ ] dude
like he's clearly jacked as [ __ ] that's
a very strong individual
if you asked me to paint a picture of
what someone who would binge
744 like like an empty bar if you
asked me to paint a picture of what they
might look like
it would look a lot like this dude so
it's certainly possible
but until he puts up 700 plus on the
platform
i'm somewhat skeptical but that video
will be linked
you can watch it for yourself uh and
draw your own conclusions
and hey hopefully it's legit i mean i'd
love to see him and maddox you know
that would be incredible going back and
forth pushing each other a little bit
that would be great
so yeah i'm i'm very optimistic that
that was
uh super super legit that'd be awesome
yeah i mean
a few years ago i think sarajev
more or less retired because no one
really challenged him
uh there's a part of me that fears
that if julius maddox benches 800 he'll
say like
well okay i'm probably not gonna break
900 i knocked down
what might be the last hundred pound
barrier for raw bench press
ah who cares i'm done he's had some peck
issues maybe he'd want to get out of the
game
but if there was someone else pushing
him uh
i mean who who knows where the two of
them could end up so yeah i
i to be clear i hope it's real
uh and i hope we see even more just
ridiculous bench presses in the future
let's hope so
all right uh moving on i've got a little
research review and you've got one as
well
after i finish up so mine's pretty quick
and to the point
but it's about a very common supplement
[Music]
fish oil it's very common very popular
and one of the things about fish oil is
because you could mechanistically
link it to just about anything there's a
lot of fanfare
about fish oil and its potential
applications
so you can make a mechanistic link to so
many different things that people say oh
yeah i take fish oil because it does
this that and the other thing for me
and it's an interesting supplement
because there might be really good
evidence for one of those three things
and really poor evidence for the other
two um but
people just kind of want to dichotomize
it and say is fish oil
effective or not and you really have to
go
outcome by outcome to assess what fish
oil can really do
as a dietary supplement so when it comes
to lifters
you know a lot of people take fish oil
just for general health
and wellness purposes
but some people take it as a lifter
hoping that it will
enhance their recovery help them build
muscle help them lose fat
you know help them get stronger and so
there's a recent
systematic review that looked at some of
these lifting-related
outcomes so it was a systematic review
by lopez
sewan and colleagues and what they did
was they looked at the effects
of omega-3 pufas or
polyunsaturated fatty acids
looking at omega-3 polyunsaturated
fatty acid supplementation on
hypertrophy
strength and delayed onset muscle
soreness when combined with exercise
and they looked at a bunch of kind of
related
outcomes so they got 15 studies
pulled together with a total of 461
individuals in this
systematic review 14 of the studies
looked at effects on muscle strength
only six looked at muscle hypertrophy
the conclusions they came to after
systematically going through the
literature section by section
is that omega-3 polyunsaturated fatty
acids fish oil supplementation
does not improve muscle hypertrophy
muscle strength or skeletal muscle
biomarkers of
inflammation and muscle damage uh beyond
what you would expect to just see you
know beneficial effects of training
itself
however in this systematic review they
did find pretty good evidence that
supplementation improved recovery in
terms of delayed onset muscle soreness
and various indices of muscle function
during the recovery phase and so
i want to look at some of the evidence
that went into this systematic review
but
before we get to the really specific
stuff
just starting at the beginning when
we're talking about polyunsaturated
fatty acids omega-3
polyunsaturated fatty acids the ones
that are are
most common most notable are fish oil
okay and that is
epa and dha those are the two
specific fatty acids that we that we
associate with the effects of fish oil
so
when you see a study on fish oil
supplementation it's likely to have
some combination of epa and dha
and these are critical components of
cell membranes they are present in
a wide range of cells and tissues
throughout the body
and so for that reason you've got papers
that are trying to link fish oil
supplementation to
uh you know muscle outcomes as we
already discussed
immune function oxidative stress
inflammation
brain health eye health cardiovascular
health
just about everything now the reason
that people would bother to supplement
with
epa or dha is because we
can convert ala
to both of them in a roundabout way but
that conversion is
really inefficient and so it's if
possible it's great to get some epa and
dha from your diet
now if you're just trying to get some
epa and dha for just
general health and well-being a lot of
the big
national and international health
organizations say hey shoot for like
0.3 to 0.5 grams a day of combined
epa plus dha and that's usually how the
dosing is discussed is the combined
total of your epa plus your dha
and if you're eating fatty fish a couple
times a week
you know then you're likely to get
around there
without needing any targeted
supplementation but
you know some people do like to
supplement and of course there's a lot
of literature looking into different
supplementation protocols
just to make sure i don't get accused of
over simplifying here i do want to
acknowledge on the front end
you know like i said the dosing for fish
oil you usually talk about
compo combined epa plus dha
the more research comes out the more
we're starting to see
that epa and dha
have some distinct effects uh
and so for example it's starting to look
like epa
might be more effective for reducing
cardiovascular
issues and it's also possible
not just that epa is kind of driving the
the ship there
in terms of preventing cardiovascular
events but that
the inclusion of dha might actually
interfere with that
so not just that the dha isn't doing
anything
but there's they're almost starting to
imply looking at some of these big
clinical trials that
you're better off for those outcomes
with epa alone
rather than the same amount of epa with
dha along with it
uh which is really interesting i i don't
have a good enough grasp on that
literature to get into the
the details of why dha would be
interfering there
is it possible that it's just a
government psyop to try to
build positive associations around the
fake news environmental
protection agency uh it's very possible
um
there's a lot of folks saying it i'm
actually hearing it more and more
uh these days but anyway uh
so but but it's not it's not fair to say
that because of that
epa is across the board better uh you
know dha
seems to be better for certain uh brain
and eye related outcomes so
it's it's kind of a mixed bag in terms
of which one you want to go for and so
it's really challenging people will ask
me hey
should i should i do epa or dha or both
and
i i don't really know how to answer that
question without asking well
what are you trying to do here that's
kind of you have to get
really specific there and if you're not
doing it for a very targeted specific
outcome
if it's just kind of a broad spectrum
overall wellness thing
then in that case i usually just go for
a combination
um so anyway that's the overview
on fish oil uh but but specifically
looking at fish oil and recovery there's
actually a growing body of literature
here
so uh there was a study recently by van
dusseldorf and colleagues
in 2020 and they did seven and a half
weeks of supplementation with either
two four or six grams a day of fish oil
uh and just to be clear six grams of
fish oil does not mean six grams of
combined epa and dha
so there is uh you know
epa and dha are kind of the active
ingredients of fish oil
but there are you know six grams of fish
oil only gives you about 4 200
milligrams of combined epa and dha with
the product they used in this study
uh you have to look at the specific
product you're you're you're
intending to buy that's a pretty high
wait
so six grams was 44 it was 4.2 grams
yeah yeah that's a pretty high potency
supplement right yeah yeah
that's on the higher end of the range
that i've seen yeah a lot of them
it's it's much lower so when you're
looking at fish oil supplementation
yeah and there's like the ethyl ester
form and there's the triglyceride for it
like
there's different ways to try to really
condense that dosing
and get the ratio of epa dha to total
grams of oil
you can try to jack that up with
different methods of of producing the
supplement
but yeah if you're looking into this
you've got to be very mindful of
okay if i take two grams as capsules
how much actual epa and dha am i getting
you know so uh anyway what they found in
this study was
uh that the six gram per day group
uh had more favorable uh recovery when
looking at things like vertical jump
soreness
and and also some blood biomarkers of
muscle damage
um and so in that study it was like well
the six gram a day
seemed to be a little bit better off uh
when compared to the two and four gram
per day
the two and four gram per day there
really wasn't much of an effect
and so you know looking at that small
study in isolation you think oh i guess
you got to go big
or go home but there are several other
studies
that have looked at various fish oil
doses
and have found beneficial effects when
it comes to
either soreness recovery following
pretty
uh pretty rigorous exercise or
restoration of muscle function
following pretty challenging exercise so
joris and colleagues looked at three
grams per day of combined epa and dha
phil pot and colleagues looked at 1.1
grams per day of combined
epa and dha black and colleagues
they also i believe we're looking at 1.1
grams combined
and found some benefits there there's
also a couple studies by
tsuchiya and colleagues looking at about
860 milligrams combined so
there have been quite a few studies
looking at this particular topic
including one from our buddy grant
tinsley and colleagues
and generally speaking it does look like
there's some pretty strong evidence here
that
fish oil supplementation can facilitate
recovery from you know
unaccustomed exercise but the same
caveat applies that i that i kind of
always put out there
when it comes to recovery supplements
and that is
you have to you know when they put a
study like this together
they need to induce something that's
going to
really really challenge your ability to
recover
right so they might pull you in and say
do this eccentric
exercise that you're totally
unaccustomed to
we're gonna you know ramp up the muscle
damage and really just beat you up with
this exercise
and that makes sense from a research
context because
you need to have a problem to solve with
the supplement right
but that's not usually how we go about
our training we don't say i'm gonna go
in and pick something that i'm totally
unaccustomed to
purely for the sake of it being hard so
whenever you look at the studies that
show like you know beneficial effect of
antioxidants on recovery or a beneficial
effect of fish oil on recovery
you have to remember that your day to
day training probably doesn't look like
these exercise protocols that are being
utilized in research
also you have to recognize that your
day-to-day training
over time you'll become accustomed to it
repeated bout effect kicks in
uh you develop more familiarity with
that
form of exercise these enormous
challenges to your recovery are not
going to be quite as severe as what we
see in these studies so
you know you have to keep that in mind
when you look at these results
you know i also wonder the degree to
which
publication bias and the the file drawer
effect
uh would would impact this particular
area of literature because
i mean you know these aren't these
aren't studies with like a
16-week lead-in period or a longitudinal
training intervention
i mean pretty much any human research is
going to be pretty labor-intensive but
as far as studies in our field go this
would be one of the
kind of less labor intensive designs and
the
the actual thing being tested uh
is relatively cheap and easily available
so
like i i wouldn't be shocked if there
were some null
some null results that people were just
sitting on uh
not for nefarious reasons just you know
not really seeing a point of publishing
them
like i'm not proposing that that
has in fact occurred and that i have
evidence that that occurred but like
i mean publication bias exists and this
this seems like an area where it would
be
more likely to show up than other areas
yeah and for me i've got kind of a
sliding scale when i assess like
are we in like the red category of high
alert publication bias or like the
orange pretty high risk of publication
buys
so the things that i think of are the
duration of supplementation
and then was there a
supervised training intervention
throughout you know so
when it comes to studies like man uh
acute caffeine supplementation
you can get three lifetimes worth of
caffeine powder
for like 20 bucks you know so the study
cost for that
if you have the testing equipment and
all your funding is
buying the caffeine it's a virtually
free study
and it's an acute action acute onset
supplement so you could bring in a
participant for this testing
the entirety of the labor going into
testing one participant in that study
is i don't know four hours right so you
think of a study like that and a
journal's only going to make you
recruit 18 or 19 people for your
crossover trial
i mean that in terms of time and money
that's about as quick and easy as study
you can do
so that's like in the red zone high
alert you got to watch out for
publication bias yeah
that's people who haven't done research
listening to this
may not have like time intensive
calibration
for research uh in the back of their
head you might have heard that in
like oh 18 19 people four hours per
person
that sounds like a lot of time
investment but compared to like a
longitudinal training study it's
nothing no absolutely not um
yeah like my uh my thesis project
or my dissertation project it was like a
solid uh
14 16 hours per participant so yeah
if you can get a participant in a
crossover trial in and out in four hours
which
includes with caffeine like a 30 60
minute wait time where they're just kind
of reading the paper
like that that's that that's a quick
efficient study and it's cost effective
as well so
when you see a study like that you gotta
you gotta think i wonder if anybody did
this study found nothing i was just like
ah who cares why bother
um and like you said it's not nefarious
it's just a researcher has probably
six data sets that they ought to be
turning into a paper at any given time
and it's like uh
is this the one thing i feel most
compelled to get out to the world
in many cases it's not uh and so a lot
of these studies
this is a very long-winded way to
express what i'm saying but
these a lot of these studies are you
know
multiple-week supplementation not
particularly cheap um
but uh some of them have training
protocols throughout the multi-week
trial some don't so yeah it's kind of in
that
i agree with you it's it's not like it's
like a 16-week really intensive training
study it's kind of in that middle ground
between
a really thorough training study and a
single afternoon caffeine study or just
cross-sectional body composition
assessment type study so
it's definitely a good point there could
be potentially an influence of some
publication bias but
you know looking at like i said uh
looking at the individual studies i got
pretty
pretty deep into this literature not not
long ago because i was writing a mass
article
about the topic and there's some pretty
solid evidence out there that
you know taking uh fish oil uh
it seems to be pretty helpful if you're
trying to recover from
uh you know a pretty extensive exercise
so
if you're noticing that you're in a
recovery deficit and you don't seem to
be recovering
as well as you think you ought to be of
course you want to take a look at your
diet you want to take a look at your
training to see if there's some really
important stuff to fix
but fish oil might offer a nice little a
little boost on top of that
but one of the things i also want to
bring attention to
is there were some initial studies that
promoted some
excitement about fish oil is like you
know something for body composition and
strength
i just don't see enough there to really
get excited about when it comes to
fish oil for strength fish oil for
hypertrophy or fish oil for fat loss
those are things people have been
getting pretty
jazzed about over the last five or ten
years but
i'm just not seeing enough solid
evidence to to suggest that
that you can expect anything that's
really going to
meaningfully move the needle there you
know
and that's one of the things to keep in
mind when you're when you're looking at
a body of literature and people are
arguing
does this effect exist or does it not
exist
and there's multiple studies on the
topic that alone kind of sets your
expectation level
right so like uh one of the big things
that
researchers go back and forth about is
do does resting metabolic rate
specifically
drop in response to weight loss
and people go back and forth and this is
in weight stable folks now if you're
still in a deficit your resting
metabolic rate is probably pretty low
relative to baseline but the big debate
is
in weight stable folks after they've
lost 20 30 pounds
has resting metabolic rate dropped more
than it should have
based on their changes in body mass and
people go back and forth about that but
the fact that it's
disputable kind of sets your expectation
with regard to the magnitude right
so if if there's 30 papers on the topic
and people argue about whether or not
it exists at the very least you can
probably
pretty confidently infer it's not a huge
effect
if it was that debate would have been
settled a long time ago
that that's kind of how i set my
expectations for some of those other
outcomes with fish oil
if we're still going back and forth
about you know in a yes no fashion
does that effect exist it kind of helps
you
set your expectations pretty low for the
actual magnitude and the importance of
any effect that might be observed there
now like i said a lot of times
general health organizations they'll say
hey get like 0.3.5 grams a day
of combined epa and dha
people who are kind of chasing the extra
benefits of fish oil and going for the
higher doses
they might go up to like one to three
grams per day
of combined epa and dha um
i personally don't like to go too far
above that
and and one thing to keep in mind is you
know
i i like getting uh things from food
whenever i can you know like so i've
written a lot about nitrate
people say what nitrate supplement
should i take i say just eat
eat green stuff spinach rock rocket or
arugula depending on
where you live but you know i like to
get stuff from food if i can
um but if you're trying to get a ton of
fish oil from eating fish itself you
want to be
you you wanna pick your fish uh
thoughtfully you know you wanna make
sure
that you're not eating a ton of fish
that are
uh you know predators way high on the
food chain
or bottom feeders you want to avoid the
species that are most likely to
accumulate really high levels of
environmental contaminants and
if you're like me you're on the road to
enlightenment you're reading all your
buddhism
books and you stopped eating meat and
fish
you can also get epa and dha from algae
oil supplements
and i actually tried my first algae oil
supplement not too long ago
i liked it a lot like a lot of times
with fish oil supplements people
complain
about kind of like the the fishy burps
that you can get which is
that's two words that just sound awful
together oh
i think it's a feature not a bug that's
absolutely disgusting but the algae oil
supplements i actually thought were
really great when it comes to that
i've got a lot of good positive
associations around childhood memories
just
hanging out at the pier fishing
you know with with my dad and my uncles
and so
very strong fish smells in the air
that's so gross anything any fish
associated smell uh as long as it's not
like you know putrid and rotten i think
it's pretty good
you need to read some amazon reviews and
they will uh
talk you out of that perspective i think
any fish oil supplement you're going to
get like 10 bad reviews that are like oh
every time i take it i burp and it
smells like fish they should have had
better childhoods i don't know what to
tell you
yeah that's a good point uh now while
we're on this topic just the last thing
i want to mention here uh
you may have seen some really
aggressive scare mongering about
polyunsaturated fatty acids
so while we're on the topic i figure at
least at least acknowledge it
um polyunsaturated fatty acids are like
the insulin of the fatty acid world
because insulin could could
theoretically be tied to so many things
mechanistically
it's like there's just volumes of blog
posts about it
and unsaturated fatty acids kind of fall
in that same trap where it's like i
could link these to almost anything
and boy will i you know and then you
just
you just write volumes and volumes of
blog posts
um now i'm certainly not indicating that
polyunsaturated fats are
you know some kind of miraculous
superfood or anything like that
you can make you know there there are
people who go back and forth about
the relative value of replacing
saturated fat
with an equal amount of polyunsaturated
fatty acid
um but there was a really nice
meta-analysis not too long ago that
kind of framed it as such so if we were
to replace
a given amount of saturated fat
with an equivalent amount of different
types of fats
what effects would we see on total
mortality
cardiovascular disease mortality cancer
mortality
and neurodegenerative disease mortality
and so you look at unsaturated fatty
acids in general
you see significant positive effects
when it comes to
all of them monounsaturated fatty acids
significant positive effects when it
comes to total mortality
and neurodegenerative disease mortality
not much going on in this particular
meta-analysis with cardiovascular
and cancer mortality looking at
polyunsaturated fatty acids significant
positive effects when it comes to total
cardiovascular cancer mortality
and also neurodegenerative disease
mortality
and this study also looks specifically
at omega-3s
um small positive effects on
neurodegenerative and total
mortality not much of an effect with
cardiovascular disease mortality or
cancer mortality
uh so this was a great paper and like
one of the things was
uh like kind of the face validity check
with this particular paper was like how
does trans fat do
very bad trans fat not
not doing great in these particular
forest plots
so uh that was like my initial validity
check that that checked out so
fish oil and polyunsaturated fats in
general
they are fine uh usually uh
what i what i what i personally aim for
in my diet is
you know a moderate fat intake that's in
line with most recommendations and then
just an even split of
saturated monounsaturated and
polyunsaturated fat
and if you look at the guidelines for
general health cardiovascular health
even
supporting testosterone production going
for a pretty even split with a
low to moderate fat intake pretty much
checks off
everything you're looking for there so
just wanted to comment on
some of the uh scare mongering related
to polyunsaturated fats and
yeah if you're interested in fish oil
you know like i said dosing in the one
to three gram per day range seems
you know doesn't seem like you're
risking much in the process
aside from the cost of the supplement i
wouldn't expect any magic but not a bad
idea to at least get some epa and dha
in the diet and of course if you're
going to do any high dose
supplementation of anything
you might want to run it by a medical
professional just to make sure that
you're
looking good makes sense to me
cool man i remember maybe like
uh 15 years ago or so when uh
when the first research related to
uh omega-3s potentially aiding in
resistance training recovery
when i i don't even know if any studies
were out or if it was just people
discussing mechanisms but
i remember when that was like
a hot topic in the supplement game
i don't remember what brand it was i
think it was biotest but
i've slandered them so much on this
podcast already that i don't want to
confidently make that assertion because
i'm sure
of so many other ridiculous claims that
they've made
i don't need to tarnish them with
something when i'm not sure about it
yeah so i don't know if it was bio test
maybe it was but it was some supplement
brand they were
they were hawking uh you know supposedly
like superior quality omega-3 supplement
and their their dosing recommendations
were basically
look start at five grams per day
uh of fish oil which is like a pretty
that's a that's a modest dose
yeah um and then just ramp up from there
at some point you will start having
steatorrhea
you'll have oily poops that you have a
hard time keeping in
not good that's that's not what you want
to happen so so you just
drop back like two grams from there and
boom that's the optimal fish oil dose
they were basically proposing
which this is a very convenient thing to
propose
if you're making money from selling the
product it was basically
take as much of our product as possible
without [ __ ] your guts out and
there's there's no
there's no risk other than [ __ ] your
guts out
uh but yeah you're gonna recover so fast
it's gonna be great
you might live forever uh risk of
cardiovascular disease
will drop to zero so uh man it was
it was truly great stuff what a risky
proposition
for a user base that is definitely
squatting and deadlifting on a regular
basis
well and the thing is like that's uh
that's the kind of like smooth brain
take you'd expect to see on
like the bodybuilding.com forums but
that was like
specifically in the marketing material
from
the supplement company like and i'm just
thinking purely from a marketing
perspective
you don't want to go out there and say
like look if you take too much of our
product
you are going to [ __ ] your pants and in
fact
you want to get to the point where you
[ __ ] your pants
because of our product and then just
pull back a little bit you know like
for anything else that we would
recommend to people
in the gym like you know you want to say
like okay what's the optimal
training volume for biceps just do curls
until you [ __ ] your pants a little bit
and then pull back you know do curls
until your urine looks like iced tea
yeah and now you've achieved rhabdo and
you scale it back
and cut volume by ten percent you're
good to go oh god uh
but man great stuff great stuff
all right so i believe you have a
research review i'm interested to hear
this one this is
a topic that um i don't want to steal
your thunder but
may i may i divulge the topic at minimum
yeah sure
so you're going to talk about it's your
podcast i'm just a guest that's true
you're going to talk about classifying
responders and
this is one of those topics that i keep
promising myself
i'm going to do a very deep dive into it
and i just
keep kicking that can down the road
there's only
there's only so many topics you can look
into at a given time
but i'm curious to see what you have to
share about this yeah well i i
might be about to give you license to
continue kicking it down the road
cool um so yeah in the journal sweep
this past month
a a study popped up by
islam and colleagues the title is
repeatability of
training induced skeletal muscle
adaptations in active young males
pulled up the study and i saw that it
was basically a secondary analysis
of a paper published in january of last
year
uh by the same by i believe the same
research group
um and so basically it for for both of
these papers for this
one study that that two papers have come
out of
uh they were interested in
uh seeing how reliable
responder classifications were so
just for some background there's a lot
of discourse
related to classifying
how well people respond to training in
general and various types of training
stimulus
so or training stimuli so a lot of these
studies will split people
into high moderate and low responders
they used to say non-responders i think
that terminology has fallen out of favor
uh for good reason i don't think that's
particularly good terminology so i'm
glad that they've switched to low
responders
uh but basically you put people through
a standardized
training protocol for you know several
weeks
uh several months and you see how well
people respond
and then generally you split them either
just
50 50 high and low or into three groups
high medium and low
and then what a lot of these papers are
interested in is seeing what factors
predict
how well someone will respond to
training so
you know we'll
just use an example which isn't
predictive
uh does like testosterone level predict
how well people will respond to training
like do
people with high testosterone levels
build more muscle than people with
somewhat lower testosterone levels so
like that that's the type
of thing that these studies would be
looking at um
and so you know this has practical
utility because
if we can uh predict
based on uh easily measurable factors
whether someone will respond well to
training or not
uh that could be really really valuable
for say like talent identification
for sports uh or you know
uh a hurdle people have to exercise
is you know people tend to
like and enjoy things that they're well
suited for so
you know i i've talked to a lot of
people who like their doctors told them
like ah
you need to go run you need to jog like
that's good for you and
like they just never got that much out
of it and they [ __ ] hated it and then
they went to the gym one time and
lifted some heavy weights and said oh
hell yeah like this is what i was meant
for and
you know respond well to resistance
training and then stick with it and
the i i don't want to make it sound like
it only goes in that direction
uh the the reverse certainly happens
uh pretty frequently as well so you know
if we could predict like what type of
training someone
would respond pretty well to uh that
could be
you know useful from a public health
perspective so you know
there are um you know very
reasonable uh motivations for
uh researching this but uh
if you're gonna do those studies you
wanna make sure
that you're actually getting useful data
from them
and one of the aspects of that is you
want to know
that you're at that you're accurately
classifying how well
people respond to training um
and so this whole concept has been
criticized
in the literature previously and and
those criticisms have taken
uh generally two main tracks so
uh one very very common criticism to
these types of studies are that
ultimately you're just
investigating typically one stimulus so
if you want to know how if you want to
know if someone responds well to
resistance training
if you're designing a study to
investigate that
fundamentally you're exposing them to a
single training program
and i'm sure a lot of people have
experienced this before like
you try one style of training yeah maybe
maybe it doesn't go great for you
you try some other style of training and
you build a lot of muscle get a lot
stronger like
some other style of resistance training
just agrees with you better
so you know ultimately these studies
aren't
in a generalized sense identifying high
and low responders they're they're
identifying high and low responders to a
particular training stimulus so that's
that's a pretty substantive criticism of
these studies
uh and then another thing is you know
you're probably dealing with just
measurement error and regression to the
mean in these studies as well so
you know no measurement is perfect and
um you know in
in theory the measurement errors are are
going to be
uh evenly dispersed about zero hopefully
as long as it's a reasonably precise and
accurate measurement
but once you've already taken the
measurements
in hindsight people who are high
responders very well
may be benefiting from some degree of
measurement error in their favor
you know you uh like if you're taking
say a biceps thickness measurement maybe
the people who are classified as high
responders
maybe their biceps are measured as
slightly smaller than they actually were
at baseline and slightly larger than
they actually were at post-testing
so you have some degree of measurement
error and then you could run into issues
with regression to the mean and so
you know unless you're seeing really
really
huge changes and differences between
responder groups uh you know just
because no measurement is perfect
you need to be a little bit cautious
when you're
talking about splitting people into
different responder groups
so so those are the two flavors of
criticism
that are often bandied about when people
talk about
you know high medium low responders to
training
but now we're getting back to the actual
studies
that i came across recently and they
bring up they bring up
another point and i think a very very
substantive issue with this whole
like research paradigm and that is
ideally if you're classifying people as
high medium low responders you want to
know that that is a
reliable classification so
if you expose someone to a particular
trading stimulus and they respond well
to it
if you expose them to the same training
stimulus again
will they respond well to it again if so
then you can confidently say like okay
this person's a high responder they
respond really well to this training
stimulus and vice versa
if you expose them to the same stimulus
multiple times
and they respond poorly both times okay
they really don't respond that well to
the stimulus so
you know you can get an idea of how
reliable those classifications are
and that's hard to i don't even know if
you could
do that with resistance training just
because there are there are residual
training effects
so you know we we've talked about the
concept of muscle memory
on the on the podcast before you know
maybe it's due to myonuclei
maybe it's due to some epigenetic
regulation
maybe it's due to some micro rna stuff
like who knows
there are a lot of potential mechanisms
that could explain
the muscle memory phenomenon but it
exists uh
i think that's pretty uncontroversially
true
um and so i i don't even know
if you could investigate this in a
resistance training context
unless you are going to have people lay
off of training for like two years
in between exposing them to the same
training about but
that would be a really really tough
study to do so
now we're getting back to these papers
these were high intensity
interval training studies so what they
did
uh is they recruited a group of 10
active young males um
and they put them through or no no the
the original paper had 14 and then the
follow-up study
they had all of the measures needed for
10. so 14
active young males initially put them
through four weeks of standardized
high-intensity interval training
they measured various protein responses
and also changes in vo2 max and
time to task failure uh in a like
standardized
uh aerobic bout uh
and then they had them d train for three
months
and then they put them through the exact
same training program again
and took the exact same set of measures
pre and post
and basically they wanted to see how
how well the within subject
pre to post changes would correlate
from the first exposure to that training
to the second
and so anything related to
something cardiovascular is a good
uh that's a good way to investigate this
question because you don't have the same
sort of muscle memory mechanisms with
cardio that you do with resistance
training
so the the three month washout period
should be more than sufficient to get
rid of the adaptations that were seen
the first time around
so you know what were the results
did they find that uh training responses
were reliable that high responders to
the first month of training were also
high responders to the second month of
training and vice versa for low
responders
they found that none of the adaptations
they looked at were reliable
so uh people who were high responders
for vo2 max the first time around
weren't necessarily the second time
around same was true for time to task
failure
same was true for a lot of the like
protein
molecular responses they looked at same
was true for capillary density
they found that all of these adaptations
were not reliable
so if they only did the first
month long block of training they split
people into high moderate and low
responders
who knows if those would have been
accurate classifications because
after a second month of uh high
intensity interval training after that
three month washout period
they would have had a completely
different mix of high moderate and low
responders
and so i think this is a
i think this is both pretty uh
explanatory for some of the
confusing aspects of of this style of
study
and i think that this is a very very
substantive issue with these studies
if we can't know that uh responderness
classification
is a reliable thing it's hard to take
much away from these studies
and like i said i think this is pretty
explanatory
because when we when we look at the
strength research in this area
where we look at research trying to see
what factors predict whether someone
will be a high medium or low responder
to training
the predictors in some of those studies
are all over the place
so at least one paper is found that
high responders are more likely to have
elevated ribosome biogenesis which
you know that's intuitive that makes
sense but i don't think that's been
replicated
another paper found that it had to do
with androgen receptor density
i don't think that's been replicated uh
the the early papers by
bauman and patrella found that it was
myonuclei adaptations and satellite cell
adaptations
i think that's been replicated once but
has failed to replicate in a few other
papers
one more recent study found that it
might have something to do with
micro rna so you know there have been a
lot of individual
factors that in one or two studies
seem to predict who will respond well to
resistance training and who won't
respond well but then
those factors seem to not replicate
super well
[Laughter]
and if it's just simply a factor of
the studies doing a relatively poor job
of reliably identifying who the quote
unquote true
high responders and quote unquote true
low responders are
i feel like that would totally explain
it
and honestly this matches my personal
experience as well like looking back
over my training history
there have been times that i've
responded really really well to training
largely due to stuff going on outside of
the gym like
am i eating well am i sleeping enough
do i have a normal life or am i working
80 hours a week
those are those are important questions
that
very strongly predict how well i'm going
to respond to my training program
and i think you know taking a bird's-eye
view i've got
15 years of training experience i think
i know pretty well that
overall i'm a high responder to
resistance training
but if you took that snapshot of me in
certain
two three month blocks in my life you'd
say greg knuckles
he doesn't respond worth [ __ ] to
resistance training which
would clearly not be true you know um
so yeah yeah i think uh i think these
were some really cool studies to be
clear
i don't think we need to put all of our
eggs in this particular basket
one key weakness of these studies uh
were that
the training periods were only four
weeks long a piece
and so in general if you're trying to
if you're trying to find associations in
stuff
just in general the more spread out your
data are
generally the easier it is to find
correlation so
you know if the total spread of change
in vo2 max
is like uh the the worst is like
minus one ml per kg and the best is like
plus five you know that data's not
spread out a ton
if the range was something like minus
three to plus
15 you may have an easier time finding
uh stronger associations from one
training period to the next so
i i do think that this study might
slightly
underestimate how reliable uh responder
classification is
just due to how short the training
period was
um so you know if you took these studies
at face value you'd say none of this
[ __ ] is reliable
at all uh and i do think that that would
probably
be jumping to too firm of a conclusion
uh and the other thing is
you know to be clear they were looking
at uh
responses to high-intensity interval
training it very well could be that
these things would be more reliable if
this was
a a theoretical resistance training
study that somehow
figured out how to overcome the
challenges
associated with muscle memory to study
this in a resistance training context so
it
it could be that that uh classifying
responders
you have really poor reliability with
high intensity interval training but
maybe it would be a lot higher with
resistance training so
you know that's certainly a possibility
but i i do think that this is
uh that this shows another
i would say it's evidence against
the utility of this type of research
until
we can have more confidence
not just in the instrumentation not just
in
whether people will respond robustly to
the generalized training stimulus and
not just a single program
uh adding to that the fact that we don't
even know
if the classification is reliable i i do
think that this should
decrease our confidence in the
uh the conclusions that that we can draw
from this
type of research unfortunately i do
think that's unfortunate because i
i think the research is really cool and
i think it would have
a lot of potential applications if we
could have a lot of faith in it
for the reasons i laid out at the start
of this segment talent identification
figure out what type what generalized
type of training people will respond
well to for maybe public health reasons
yadda yadda
i i wish we could have a lot of faith in
this
type of research but uh
i i think that this is another just one
more factor that weakens my confidence
in it
you know that was really bold you
self-identified as a person who
responds to training um i appreciate
uh that you are honest about that my my
path has been totally different i'd say
in terms of genetics i'm easily bottom
two or three percent
um but i i simply wanted it
more than anyone else and i'm really
proud of me for that honestly and i also
developed
a pretty foolproof training system that
will supercharge gains for
literally anybody so it's interesting
that we have these two different paths
to our
our lifting pursuits sure yeah yeah um
i have to share anytime the
the topic of responders comes up um
i was reading a supplement paper one
time and uh
they're like okay i know where you're
going with this
they're like okay so we studied this
supplement does the supplement work
obviously not um but like what are we
supposed to do
just say it doesn't work come on be
realistic be an adult so
they're like listen did you know that
there are such things as non-responders
perfect we got that settled so what
we're going to do is just separate out
the non-responders
who we're just going to arbitrarily
identify as just like
the people who didn't get better from
the supplement and then if we only
analyze the data from the responders
clearly the supplement works and it's
like you know if
if you had a study where the goal was to
stay
weight stable you're going to have a
percentage of the group
that loses a little weight you're going
to have a percentage that gains a little
weight
you're going to have a small percentage
that truly is dead on the money
and so it's like just doing a study like
that and be like damn if we only look at
the people who gained weight
this was actually a weight gain study
when you look at it
so yeah i just that's the thing that
really got me
interested in in getting more into the
statistical
side of identification more so than the
physiological side was i was
i've seen a couple papers like that i'm
like somebody has to step in
i think this is this is horrific what's
happening here
yeah but uh but no that was really
interesting and
it has uh given me even more license to
delay my interest in looking into this
so i appreciate that
glad to hear it uh i i mean if if i'm
gonna come on your podcast as a guest
i see it as my duty to
give you license to do things that you
already wanted to do awesome
i think that's just good guest behavior
yeah
all right man uh let's get to some q and
a's and then we'll then we'll wrap it up
for the day
let's do it how does that sound um i'll
go ahead and knock out a couple of mine
and then you can do yours after that
sounds good so i got a question from
somebody and by the way if you're like
listening to see if your question is
getting answered here
i go back to the original spreadsheet
for these because i i stockpiled a bunch
of questions
so i might be answering questions that
were asked like
i don't know in obama's first term uh
that's kind of the time frame i'm
working with here but anyway
this one is from greg's brownie recipe
the question is is there any validity to
the idea that athletes should avoid
using things like non-steroidal
anti-inflammatory drugs or
fish oil in order to better realize
training adaptations
and you see greg that's what separates
the permanent hosts from the temporary
hosts is that i tied that in to my
research review we got the fish oil in
the question i've been saving this
all along so for young healthy folks
it's probably not a bad idea to avoid
regular use of high-dose non-steroidal
anti-inflammatory drugs when we
implement training and we induce a
training stimulus
there are some aspects of acute
inflammatory processes that seem to be
part of the remodeling and adaptation
process so there are some studies
indicating that for young healthy folks
regular use of high-dose non-steroidal
anti-inflammatory drugs
can blunt training adaptations to an
extent
similar evidence exists for high-dose
use
of vitamin c and vitamin e so these are
obviously antioxidants
the thing that's interesting though
about the antioxidant component
is that from the data we have available
which is not much
that effect with vitamin c and vitamin e
does not seem to be as big of a deal
with phytochemicals with antioxidant
properties so like
you know people use different like
polyphenol rich
you know blueberry extract or
pomegranate extract or things like that
and a lot of those uh antioxidant
phytochemicals
mechanistically reduce oxidative stress
by
distinct mechanisms rather than
something like vitamin c or e
that do it much more directly when you
look at
the biochemical process of
reducing oxidative stress so there are
some mechanistic distinctions there
uh you know some of these are directly
scavenging
um free radicals some of these
are actually working through uh like
nerf 2 and enzymatic reactions so it's
not as big a deal with
plant-based antioxidant phytochemicals
and one of the really challenging things
with limiting this
antioxidant stuff is antioxidants within
certain dosing ranges can be
really nice if you're taking like a
nitric oxide booster
because nitric oxide is very unstable
has a short half-life
and if you take an antioxidant
with a nitric oxide booster a lot of the
nitric oxide instead of getting
converted to peroxynitrite
which is unfavorable it'll get pushed
toward
other pathways of nitric oxide recycling
for lack of a better term so
you can extend the bioactivity and the
half-life of nitric oxide
by pairing a nitric oxide booster with
an
antioxidant and a lot of times that just
happens
if you think about like citrulline being
naturally present in watermelon
or nitrate being naturally naturally
present in
beet juice or spinach you know there's
plenty of these phytonutrient
antioxidants that are present within the
food or the beverage matrix
so you don't want to go you know 1000
milligrams vitamin c as your typical
pre-workout
but there can be some benefit of lower
doses
of antioxidants if you're trying to
extend uh the bio activity of nitric
oxide
now one of the interesting things that's
on the horizon here
is antihistamines i have seen some
very preliminary evidence with emerging
data
that warrants some consideration i have
seen evidence that anti-histamines
taken at high doses could potentially
have
similar effects as like taking the
high-dose antioxidants or the high-dose
non-steroidal anti-inflammatory drugs
i've only seen one or two papers
so i'm not ready to like lean into it
super hard but
keep that on the on the horizon i know
greg you are you are sweating in your
chair right now
dude just imagine how [ __ ] big i
would be if i didn't have
uh [ __ ] life-threatening
seasonal allergies yeah i'm allergic to
everything
we should look more into that paper it
came out very recently i'll send it to
you
but they use two very specific
antihistamines that were not
antihistamines that i ever use regularly
it wasn't like
uh it wasn't like loratadine it wasn't
um
cetirazine yeah it was yeah it wasn't
that benadryl
i don't know if they used uh benadryl or
not i'll have to look into that but uh
but that's something to just keep on
horizon
a non-specific worry to keep you up at
night
and we'll we'll revisit that topic when
we have an opportunity to do so
a nothing can keep me up at night and i
resent the implication
uh b i as soon as we get done recording
this i'm scheduling another round of
allergy shots
really no not really i
don't want to deal with the [ __ ] u.s
healthcare system okay
here's a bad news segment we're gonna
we're gonna slot this in so as
as dedicated listeners to this podcast
know
i broke my wrist a while back correct
i had exactly two doctor's visits about
that
uh i went to urgent care they took an
x-ray they gave me a little brace
uh that was fine and then i went to uh
uh in orthopedic um
and he basically he didn't do [ __ ] uh
he saw me for three minutes and was just
like yeah uh
just like don't do much with your wrist
for a while see me in a month
uh and he was like oh yeah
the uh avulsion fracture you have like
it'll probably heal on its own so like
yeah come see me in a month we can take
more x-rays
like see if it has done that i'm like
but if it hasn't
what are you gonna do like what's the
treatment then he's like ah
well there won't really be much we can
do and i was like so why do i need to
see you again in a month
it was like ah you just need to do it so
anyway on the way out i i canceled uh
he's got a boat payment coming up yeah i
canceled the return visit
um so anyway i had a grand total of two
visits about that
yeah when i got home uh there was
there was a bill from urgent care for
like 300 bucks or something
i paid that and i was like okay i have
one more bill coming
from from the orthopedic so i was like
okay this is fine
for some reason i don't know how i
haven't looked into the details yet
i have six goddamn health care bills
on the island downstairs for various
[ __ ]
and like even if you itemize everything
that was done to me
like if if you assume there's a separate
bill for the x-ray and there's a
separate bill for
the splint they put me in and there's a
separate bill for
whatever like i i came up with a grand
total of
four things four discreet things that
maybe i could have separate bills for
and i've already paid one and i have six
left
i i got seven [ __ ] bills
for two visits i don't know how
i did i didn't think that was possible
all of which is to say
i spent over a decade of my life
never interfacing with the american
health care system
because it's so [ __ ] like from
uh from 17 to 29 i did not go to the
doctor
yeah for anything i break my wrist and i
get
seven [ __ ] bills for what amounted to
basically nothing
dude i don't care if getting allergy
shots and going off
antihistamines would turn me into the
second coming of ronnie coleman
i am never interfacing with the american
healthcare system again
unless it's life-threatening it's
it's so bad the way they itemize things
like um
when they're like walking out the door
after seeing you they'll be like all
right man good luck
like take care and you'll get a bill for
like emotional support
therapy and they're like dude i added
that therapy at the end i told you to
like have a good day
well it wasn't like itemized stuff on
one bill we're talking
seven discreet bills from different
companies
like there's different letterhead on top
of all of them i don't know how that's
possible
when i it's ridiculous yeah when i
uh got my fake cancer diagnosis
[Laughter]
so before it was allegedly cancer
they were like oh well i mean it could
be cancer but it also could be something
that is acutely
very dangerous like if it is this
alternative diagnosis you need surgery
tonight
uh and we need to do imaging to to rule
that out and i was
very very very poor very poor
and i said okay
[Music]
how much is that going to cost is this
like the type of thing i'm going to be
paying off in 10 years
and they're like honestly i couldn't
even begin to give you a ballpark figure
and i was like no i don't need a
i don't need an exact price but tell me
is it is this a hundred a thousand ten
thousand or a hundred thousand
you know a b c or d and they're like
dude i honestly couldn't even
begin to try to put and they're like the
next person
in this this uh the next person i send
you to will be able to give you an
estimate
i go to the next person and the same
thing couldn't even put me within an
order of magnitude of the cost and
they're
now the next person will tell you so all
of a sudden i'm on the table for the
imaging
and i'm like everyone keeps telling me
the next person will tell me if this
if this procedure is going to
fundamentally change the next 10 years
of my financial life
do you have the answer she's like
absolutely not i have no idea
do you want it or not and like it yeah
it was a disaster
uh and then i got the same thing a
million different bills
uh i paid the bill and then they
adjusted it after the fact and they were
like actually there's more that you owe
that's sick that's so cool yeah i paid
the bill in full and they're like
we actually we told you a number we
changed our mind you owe more now for
the same thing
uh so maybe you'll get six more in a
couple months you know
the last thing i'm gonna say about this
is as frustrating as this has been
i'm just glad that we have the freedom
that we have i agree with the private
health care system in the u.s and
you know it's i i certainly feel far
more free
than i would if if the government was
running it
for sure i agree for sure so uh
anyway getting back to the question
sorry for the impromptu bad news segment
see this is why we had to cancel the
good news segment um
so non-steroidal anti-inflammatory drugs
high dose vitamin c
or e high-dose antihistamines probably
don't want to be taking them unless you
really need them and sometimes you do
you know sometimes the benefit of the
antihistamine or the benefit of the
the non-steroidal anti-inflammatory
exceeds
the cost of potentially blowing training
adaptations for a short period of time
but as i mentioned previously fish oil
no reason to avoid it with regards to
training adaptations
it's just probably not going to help a
ton i think
fish oil's effect is either going to be
neutral
or just the slightest positive effect
that won't matter
at all because it's such a small
magnitude
now if you're an old so what we see with
aging
in in older adults is that kind of
baseline inflammatory status baseline
oxidative stress they tend to increase
as we age
especially as we get into our 50s 60s
70s and beyond
so if you're uh if you're
if you're if you're in a state where you
have kind of increased baseline
inflammation either due to aging or some
other
um you know medical reason for that
increased baseline inflammation then
throw all those recommendations out the
window
because in some cases you know doing
something like a high-dose antioxidant
or
a non-steroid steroidal
anti-inflammatory drug
in the presence of elevated baseline
inflammation
could have a neutral or even slightly
positive effect
on training adaptations so it's kind of
contextually dependent there but but
that's
uh that would be my answer to the
question as
asked um now moving on i've got
uh two questions that i'm kind of
putting together here matt rains
asked about the omad diet which is one
meal a day
correct yeah what what are my thoughts
on that
and shelov asked is it important to get
protein and leucine right before
sleep to continue muscle protein
synthesis throughout the night so
the reason i put these together is
because obviously they both relate to
protein distribution throughout the day
uh so let's start with one meal a day
um we recently saw a pretty good how-to
video for that right
we did we we learned a lot from it but
not the kind of learning you want
uh we learned about like what happens if
you combine
every possible meat in your refrigerator
ranging from fish to hot dogs
in a single meal which is not what you
want to do for health
for health hot dogs for health
no so we watched a video where somebody
was like hey i eat one meal a day
watch me eat my meal and literally the
the entire explanation of the
contents of the meal was like well
because i only eat one meal a day it
makes my life way worse and i have all
these problems i have to solve so here
is my solution
to the problems i created by only eating
one meal a day
so like every aspect of the diet was
an adjustment for the fact that it's
such a horrifically inconvenient
way to eat um but anyway so
to give a a more neutral assessment
if you're eating one meal a day because
it's the only thing that fits with your
busy schedule
uh it fits your personal eating
preferences
um you're able to feel good throughout
the day
you know you don't have like huge energy
crashes you're not feeling
shaky after a while um you know if
you're able to sustain one meal a day
it fits your preferences that's fine
like
there's nothing wrong with it um
i i don't think it's ideal uh because
it's not a great way to distribute your
protein if you're interested in
supporting
muscle protein synthesis and hypertrophy
over time
there is a temporal aspect to protein
consumption
and looking at the meal frequency
literature and looking at the acute
feeding studies
it looks like you probably want to get
you know 0.25 maybe 0.3 grams per
kilogram of protein
at at least three separate meals
throughout the day in order to support
muscle protein synthesis like that
that's kind of the lower end of what
we're seeing in studies that seem to
successfully promote hypertrophy
in conjunction with resistance training
does that mean you can't make any gains
eating one meal a day of course not
i just don't think it's the optimal way
to distribute your protein
um and one you know to be fair and
balanced
one benefit of adopting this approach is
if you are someone who struggles with
hunger and it's hard to restrict
calories
and that process becomes more manageable
when you reduce
meal frequency pretty aggressively it's
i i'm certain it's very possible that a
lot of people
will find it more manageable to reduce
their calorie intake by doing one meal a
day
i also find it very plausible
that some people might go the other
direction and because of the severe
restriction
by the time they get to their one meal
of the day they might be absolutely
starving
and potentially even over compensate
depending on what kind of food sources
they're selecting
you know if they're if they're selecting
really calorie dense
low satiety food sources that could
potentially be a
a rough scenario so one meal a day it's
it's not like it's you know the worst
thing you could possibly do but i
certainly don't think it's optimal
for protein distribution and the
question is if you're gonna be training
when are you training uh with one meal a
day uh
maybe you're training after a you know
22-hour fast
and and then you're eating your one meal
a day post-workout or
i mean i can't imagine that you're
training short after
one meal a day because like dude i'm not
going to train with
a 3 000 calorie meal in my stomach like
i'd
that'd be awful to me so i don't know
where
you're putting your training here i i
think even just going from one meal a
day to two
makes it a much more manageable eating
schedule throughout the day especially
when you consider
being in a position to train in a
well-fueled state but also being in a
position to provide nutrients
at some point post-workout now the other
question was about
sleep and protein before bed
nighttime is a great opportunity to get
one of your protein feedings for the day
and like i said you probably want at
least three distinct protein feedings
throughout the day
i used to recommend three to five based
on some of the literature looking at
temporal
aspects of stimulating muscle protein
synthesis
i reviewed a paper recently that
compared three versus six meals a day
and there was no difference they were
very very similar in terms of outcomes
so i've extended my recommended window
from three to five
up to three to six uh you know
just staying staying flexible as the
evidence comes in
uh i have no specific reason to believe
that seven meals a day is necessarily
worse but
it does start to get a little tedious
when you're eating every couple hours
and there are studies looking at
specific pulsing strategies where
doing like eight small protein feedings
was not as effective as doing like
three bigger protein feedings over a
similar time window so
there is evidence in humans looking at
protein synthesis that would indicate
that at some point
you start to lose out on the ultra
frequent small protein pulses
but um but yeah i'd say three to six
meals per day if one of them happens to
be before bed that's that's a totally
viable time to eat protein
um that you don't have to eat right
before bed
but if you do eat before bed and have a
protein serving there
you want to make sure that what you're
eating isn't going to upset your stomach
some people
really disturb their sleep if they eat
right before bed
even if they have a big protein shake
right before bed some people
struggle to sleep on a full stomach or
they you know wake up throughout the
night or wake up with a stomach ache
so you want to avoid that and there's
also some interesting evidence
related to uh so uh greg correct me if
i'm wrong but i'm pretty sure branch
chain amino acids
and tryptophan have some competition
with regards to the brain correct
that's what i've heard so i've seen some
interesting
literature indicating or suggesting that
a huge influx of branch chain amino
acids right before bed
could lead to some disruption regarding
the quantity or the quality of sleep
because of that competitive
effect with tryptophan uh and so
maybe you could use that to make the
argument that you shouldn't have like
an essential amino acid supplement or a
branched chain amino acid supplement
right before bed
maybe that extends to a very rapidly
digesting protein like
whey i personally i have whey protein
before bed all the time it's never been
an
issue and i have had sleeping issues in
the past
so maybe don't take a huge serving of
branch chain amino acids right before
bed but
even with a fast digesting protein like
whey it's not something that's bothered
me personally in the past but
it is uh a suggestion that i'm at least
aware of and worth considering
you know when you're thinking about this
makes sense to me
all right greg you got a couple
questions right i do so i have one from
annie
palladino uh so annie asks
let's say you're designing a training
program for older folks
parentheses 60 plus with no prior
training history
goals are maintaining or improving daily
functioning
and mitigating bone slash muscle loss
assuming no limits on access to
equipment which exercises do you build
the program around
either from an evidence-based
perspective or from a personal
experience
slash preferences perspective so yeah i
think that's a great question
um so i mean
obviously the answer is squad bench
deadlift uh
would you do threes or fives i would
stick to fives because that offers the
optimal balance of
strength hypertrophy and endurance
endurance good
uh oh man yeah i'm not gonna get into
that
anyway um yeah no no so uh
i would probably start with a
combination
of body weight exercises and machine
exercises
um the machine exercises just because
when you're dealing with people 60 plus
and and we're you know
i'm kind of assuming just uh an
average 65 year old no prior training
experience
probably not in great shape uh
mid 60s can look very different for
different people
there are people in their mid-60s who
are still in
excellent shape and there are people in
their mid 60s with
one and a half feet in the grave so you
know
60s i i would say like 50s and 60s are
probably the most
physiologically varied decades
that exist uh if you say like oh what
are you gonna do
for a 30 year old you have an idea of
what's going on
you ask yeah what are you going to do
for an 80 year old you got a pretty good
idea of what's going on
50 60 year olds 40 year olds anywhere
within that range
boy that could mean so many different
things dude
i saw a picture the other day of tom
cruise
he was um i guess back in the day he did
a movie
and there was like a kid that was a main
character in the movie
and there was a picture of them and tom
cruise is like a 30-something year old
man
and the kid is like six yeah the kid
looks older than tom cruise now
it's insane like like you said like
people start getting into their 50s and
60s
and some people just do not age in those
decades it's wild
getting audited uh by this church of
scientology is scientifically proven to
lengthen your telomeres
so tom cruise might physically still be
in his 20s
sweet uh that's not true anyway so
uh yeah so we're i'm just gonna assume
someone who's who's probably not
in great shape uh so yeah i would start
with a
mixture of body weight exercises and
machine exercises the machine exercises
primarily just so uh some
we we can have some things going on with
really really low
stability of requirements so you can
stress the muscles pretty hard
and when it comes to maintaining bone
mineral density and bone health
most of the forces on your bones that
you're dealing with are actually
compressive forces
from muscle contraction
so yeah i mean anything that's going to
let them contract their muscles
pretty hard is probably going to be a
pretty decent option to start with
uh and you know machines very
small learning curve pretty easy to get
into
and then bodyweight exercises because uh
you know once people start hitting their
50s
60s especially late 60s into 70s
balance starts becoming a much bigger
issue
so building and maintaining
and improving kinesthetic awareness and
just control of your body through space
is really really important um
we're where elderly people get into a
lot of trouble is
when either they have an unstable base
of support
or when say like they're reaching
and their center of mass is
getting close to the edge of just
one foot instead of having a solid two
foot base of support
so ideally you want to get to to a place
with them
where that's not as scary and that's not
as potentially problematic so you know
the body weight stuff is probably going
to start very very simple so just like
bodyweight box squats but if you can get
them
to the point where they can do even like
fairly
low strict step ups where they're
supporting themselves and balancing on
one foot for
a decent bit of time or lunges
so they have a pretty wide base of
support but maybe
not a ton of lateral stability so they
have to
activate their ankles activate their
hips to stabilize themselves so
you know starting with a very very small
step lunge and then progressing
to kind of wider and wider stances more
and more in line
things like that are going to help with
balance uh
just improving quad strength and calf
strength helps a lot
um so uh improving calf strength
helps a lot with balance and then quad
strength that's that's one of the first
things that goes with elderly people
that
really really impacts activities of
daily living
specifically just being able to stand up
and walk upstairs
quad strength seems to go pretty quick
and go in a pretty big way
so you know certainly gonna gonna be
doing probably largely machine exercises
to start with
to train the quads and the calves
and then basically we're we're primarily
using machines to build muscle build
strength
and primarily using body weight
primarily
just mostly for balance stuff like
there's still probably going to be some
degree of strength in hypertrophic
stimulus but
mostly just improving their ability to
manipulate their own body mass through
space and
and control and balance themselves uh
and then i mean from there it's just a
matter of of
where they go and how they progress you
know within
a couple months they very well could be
capable of doing just about anything
anyone else in the gym would want to do
or you know if
they've just aged faster than average
and life has been pretty rough
on them so far maybe maybe you're just
going to be doing mostly machine stuff
and
what what to the outside perspective
would look like
pretty easy bodyweight stuff but to them
would be pretty challenging bodyweight
stuff so
you know i would start with bodyweight
stuff in machines and then
progression from there just based on
on how quickly and how well they respond
to training uh
so yeah that's that's how i would
approach it uh
in terms of the skills that are going to
matter the most for maintaining
activities of daily living
um you want to have the strength and
also the balance
to manipulate objects
at various levels so being able to pick
stuff up
off the ground and also you know
probably
doing some pressing stuff so they can
control and manipulate things above
their head because
that's where people tend to get
themselves in trouble reaching up to
grab something
or you know being either unable to pick
something up off the ground or losing
balance when they do so so
those would be skills we'd work on and
then again just quad
strength for standing up out of chairs
being able to go upstairs stuff like
that
um so yeah hopefully that answers that
question
uh and then a non-training related one
from peter herguth
peter asks or he says i saw a recent
post from a friend that the
dunning-kruger effect
may be an artifact or result of a poorly
designed study for various reasons
what is your take on this so uh
i have not dug into the methodology of
kind of the seminal dunning-kruger
effect study
uh sufficiently to have a strong opinion
about the methodology
but i wanted to address this question
because i wanted to
address the interpretation of the
dunning-kruger effect that's going
around
uh i think basically we're dealing with
a meta-dunning-kruger effect
where people have where people are
exhibiting the dunning-kruger effect as
it relates
to what the dunning-kruger effect
actually is so when i see people discuss
the dunning-kruger effect
i often see them share a graphic like an
illustration
that shows confidence
as a function of competence and so
when they start off they have really no
confidence in what they're doing and
and no competence but then as competence
increases a little bit
confidence goes way way up and the the
popular graphic there has that
initial peak of confidence with
relatively low competence
labeled as mount stupid and you'll often
see that bandied around as an insult
like
oh so and so they have some hot takes
but they really don't know what they're
talking about
they're just perched at the top of mount
stupid and then as the graphic
progresses further to the right uh
competence increases knowledge increases
and then confidence
starts sloping down again off the back
of mount stupid
and then as you start you know attaining
expert status and whatever it is uh
confidence in what you know starts going
up again so
you know it's kind of like a an initial
hump then a down slope and then an
upslope and confidence again and that's
that is the graphical representation of
the dunning-kruger effect i see
people sharing around and and the idea
that i see people
uh using the dunning-kruger to represent
is people with low knowledge
having more confidence in their take
than people with
much much more knowledge about a
particular topic the thing is that is
not
what the dunning-kruger paper found it
found that there was
a positive association between
um like knowledge and competence
in the domains they were testing and
confidence so as
as uh expertise increases performance on
tests
increased and as expertise increased
confidence in your subject matter
increased
and basically what they were doing is
they were giving people tests
and they were measuring how well they
did on the test and they were asking
people
how well did you think you did on the
test
and people with low competence low
knowledge
did overestimate how well they did on
the test like you know if they scored 60
percent maybe they said like yeah i
think i got a 70.
and the people with really really high
confidence they scored
maybe a 90 and they said i think i got
an 85. so
the the highly knowledgeable people
were slightly underconfident and the low
knowledge people
were slightly overconfident but the high
knowledge people
did predict that they did better than
the low knowledge people predicted that
they did
so like so it's not like the the people
with
expertise on the topic were looking at
the people without it and going like oh
i'm sure you know more than me
like this is very complex i mean they
still thought like
i did pretty pretty damn good on this
well yeah yeah
like they yeah they did well
and they thought they did well but they
did better than they thought they did
right and the people who did poorly
thought they did
poorly yeah but they thought they did a
little bit better than they actually did
like that's what the results of that
original study indicate like that
is the dunning-kruger effect people with
low knowledge
overestimate their competence but they
don't
estimate their competence to be greater
than experts
yeah so like the thing is that graphical
representation
i think that does probably apply to some
people like you see some absolute
knuckle draggers uh really really
confident in their really stupid takes
like yeah you see plenty of that that
does happen to people but that
that is not what occurs on average like
most people who don't know much about a
topic
recognize that they don't know much
about the topic
but they might overestimate themselves a
little bit yeah and people who know a
lot about the topic
know they know a lot about the topic but
they might
underestimate themselves a little bit
like that that is the dunning-kruger
effect
um so anyway that's interesting i i
yeah i never heard that so the the
dunning-kruger effect
i i think people are dunning-krugering
the dunning-kruger effect
uh they they have a they are
they are mis-estimating their competence
in the subject matter of the dunya
effect
you know one thing that is really
interesting hopefully i can get that
link in the show notes um
you shared something on the stronger by
science facebook page today
i believe that was somewhat related to
this
because they were asking like hey is is
the dunning-kruger effect just like a
bad study design
you know that that's not actually you
know robust and reliable
you shared a link i believe to
a website that goes through a bunch of
different concepts
in psychology that are popularly
accepted and kind of known to be things
that exist in psychology
but upon further review have actually
been kind of
uh they just haven't replicated and the
field is kind of acknowledged like yeah
that's
that's not actually how psychology works
in real life
uh i thought that was really fascinating
it kind of goes to the same
uh to the same place this question was
getting at
um and man there was an extensive list
of uh what are you showing me here i'm
showing you
the figure from the well one of the
figures from the actual paper
oh yeah yeah that is not what you see
when people talk about the
dunning-kruger effect yeah we can put
the link in the show notes
yeah but yeah you shared that other link
that talks about all these different
things
that like someone like me who's just
like a lay person who doesn't know
anything about psychology i took like
psyc101
it's like oh these there's like first
day psych 101 stuff like oh
we know about this we know about that
and there are these big reversals in
psychology where
i think psychology is is trending toward
being a lot more rigorous with their
work
and people in the field currently will
probably roll their eyes and say uh
trending uh very slowly but
um but yeah it's really fascinating to
kind of revisit some of those topics we
accept as fact and then say actually
upon further review there's there's a
lot more to consider here so
i'll put that link in the show notes if
you're just kind of casually interested
in psychology
it's it's worth a read it's pretty cool
yeah and uh and
shout out to james heathers he is the
person i saw
sharing it on twitter and so uh
i mean if you're if you're interested in
uh
dodgy psychology or just meta science in
general
james heather's is a very solid follow
both on twitter and medium you should
check out his stuff
yeah but but if you listen to this show
then there's a high
likelihood that you're sensitive to
vulgarities
so probably a warning james has been
known to use foul language that you're
never going to hear on this show
as a family show okay to play us out
i've got something a little bit off
topic here it's sport related
just to give a background uh when i was
a kid i was really into baseball
i loved playing uh and
i grew up uh the the
town i lived in there was a pro baseball
team and they were in the nl central
okay so at the time mark maguire played
for the cardinals and sammy sosa played
for the cubs
and when i was a kid mark mcguire and
sosa were in town it felt like every
couple weeks
and this was when they were both hitting
like 65
70 homers like that year so like my
experience as a kid
as a baseball fan was just it was
outrageous it was
it was completely unfair because my idea
of going down to the ballpark for a game
was like
let's go watch mark mark maguire hit his
you know 68th homer this year
and just all the pandemonium surrounding
that home run race
so all of that is to say it's been
really hard for me to get back into
baseball
lately it just hasn't been as
interesting as that insanely
interesting and exciting era of baseball
but there is a feat of insanity
happening currently
and greg you actually brought this to my
attention when we were hanging out the
other day
shohei ohtani he is
a very very good pitcher and we are
watching some of his pitching
highlights he's got some really good
stuff
and if you're not familiar with baseball
uh
was it i think it's the is it the
american league or the international
league
that that has designated hitters
american league american league
so basically a long time ago in the
sport they're like listen pitchers
they're good at pitching but it's such a
specialized skill they're all terrible
at hitting and it's boring so can we
just have someone else hit
instead of the pitcher like
pitchers sucking at hitting is a widely
enough known
repeatable enough trend that half of the
league basically decided let's not
put ourselves through watching these
pitchers try to hit uh
now shohei ohtani like i said is a very
skilled pitcher
he's like at the top of the league home
run leaderboard
like he's he i saw he dropped to like
number two or three the other day but
like at certain points throughout the
season he has been the home run leader
uh i saw yeah he's currently tied again
yeah
so i saw the other day he he hit a
double a triple and a homer
with a stolen base like
he is an absolute top notch
as good as anybody hitter while also
being an extremely solid pitcher
so what he's doing right now is just
absolutely unfathomable and it's not a
feat of strength but it's a feat of
skill
that is arguably without precedent
i mean it is really remarkable what he's
doing
and i saw um you know i'm a stats guy i
saw his era dropped from 37.8 last year
to 2.85
this year so if you extrapolate that
trend and i think you should
uh it's going to be interesting in a
couple years to see what his era is
obviously last year was a fluke he like
pitched a couple
innings and got rocked and then got hurt
and couldn't play for a while
but uh anyway just insane what he's
doing really really cool to see
and i'm just stoked that baseball is
becoming interesting again
they've got some interesting uh
personalities in the sport they've got
some really great
uh athletes that are just fun to watch
right now
and they've got a cheating scandal which
is my bread and butter
and it's a cheating scandal with a
raleigh connection yeah and a lifting
connection
yeah so uh you know when i was a kid you
know everybody was doing all the
steroids but man was it fun
i mean they were knocking the ball out
of the park like crazy
and now greg like you said uh you want
to explain those connections to the
current
cheating yeah yeah so the the current
cheating scandal which they
just started cracking down on maybe like
two three weeks ago
was uh and this is something pitchers
have been doing forever
they use sticky substances to get a
better grip on the ball
uh which they they have claimed is so
they can control their pitches better
but
uh at least certainly over the last few
years once
spin rates and how to just craft in the
lab
a nasty breaking pitch once that's
become better understood
people are using stickier and stickier
substances
to up their spin rate uh increase
movement on their braking pitches uh
have less drop on their fastball so like
to the hitter it looks like it rises so
they undercut all of the fastballs and
either just
whiff or pop them up uh a high spin rate
can do some nasty [ __ ] to a baseball
and the stickier your fingers are the
more spin you can put on a ball
uh and so there there has apparently
been just an
arms race to try to find
the best sticky substances to throw the
nastiest
pitches possible and some of the teams
allegedly have in-house chemists
that are trying to devise the best
sticky substance
possible for pitching but there was a
test that like some
some independent uh like pitching
researchers
i guess um where they tested out
several known sticky substances that
uh some that baseball players have been
using forever so like a mixture of sweat
and rosin
uh then the the og illegal sticky
substance of pine tar
and then some newfangled stuff that
people have gotten caught with
one of which is spider tack owned by
uh james deffenbaul from spider strength
gym
friend of the show and he was on the
friend of the show yeah absolutely
uh it's it's tacky for doing like stones
for strongman
uh and it is apparently the best tacky
in the world as verified by baseball
um so yeah they found that spider tac
increased spin rate more than any other
non-crazy proprietary substance
and so like if you just google spider
tack now
you'll find a bunch of [ __ ] losers
and nerds
complaining that oh this stuff is too
good it makes pictures unhittable
[ __ ] you man like if if i see
a dude who's throwing 98 mile an hour
heat
that also has a curveball that drops two
feet off the table
and has like a slider that breaks
a foot and a half away from a
right-handed hitter
and a cutter that breaks eight inches
towards a right-handed hitter
and the tunneling of those pitches looks
the same until it's halfway to home
plate
that's [ __ ] sick that is so cool to
watch
uh so anyway i think
james is a true american hero and i
think
the nerds who are trying to ruin
baseball need to get out of it
uh and so you know there's
so they're cracking down on this on the
sticky substances now
very dumb very bad
because they're saying so league-wide
batting average
is the lowest it's ever been in the live
ball era and they're saying like ah
that's bad
people on tv they like to see offense
blah blah blah
we need to make the pictures worse no
bring steroids back yeah give all of the
make the pitchers use spider tack and
make the hitters use steroids
that is the recipe for awesome baseball
do you think they're gonna pull the 90s
thing all over again and have uh
james in front of congress
[Laughter]
if he spends six months on it if he's
our generation's victor conte
[Music]
oh man by the way and spider attack is
our generations the cream and the clear
yeah i mean just to be clear i mean it's
not james's fault it's not like you're
gonna spell
sell spider tech and like license it
like oh what are you using this for
you know you gotta fill out the
application i mean it's not his fault
that people are you know just
throwing these nasty curveballs but dude
i saw a video
um on instagram that it used like really
high-speed cameras
and it was a picture it superimposed the
video
of the pitcher throwing two different
pitches in a game
and one was a fast ball the other was a
breaking ball
dude these things you know you pitch
from what 60 and a half feet
yeah these things went 30 feet
literally the ball path was identical
like
fully identical the release point the
trajectory
and then in the last like at the very
last second
this pitch just falls off the table and
the fastball just keeps on going
like you know with with hitting people
say it's so hard because you have such
limited reaction time
they're like they're cutting their
reaction time in half man
these pitches they're breaking so
severely so late in the pitch i just
can't imagine how you even try to hit it
well yeah and the uh for people who have
a
very fast fastball and just those
disgusting nasty braking pitches the
whole approach to pitching has changed
so like i grew up uh in the 90s
as a big braves fan uh when greg maddox
was dominating the league with like a 81
mile an hour fastball that's only a
slight exaggeration
uh and and the name of the game to be a
dominant pitcher uh if your name wasn't
pedro martinez
was to just like have insane control
you know the the umpires back then we're
giving we're calling people
strikes like a foot a foot off the
outside corner of the plate
they're kind of liberal with some of
those strike calls but the
the name of the game was keep the ball
low keep it outside and like if you
could do that
you could have a really nice career uh
even if you didn't have
just really really nasty stuff um
but these days like people are throwing
harder
and and like i said they're designing
breaking pitches
in the lab with high-speed cameras and
pitching coaches who can like
figure out how to get get the spin like
one more
revolution on the way to home plate and
like get it to spin over the exact right
axis to break at the angle you
want and so now the name of the game
instead of painting
the the bottom like low and away it's
less a control game and more just a
do you have nasty [ __ ] game yeah uh
because if you have you know if you have
a high 90s fastball
and then you have a slider in the low
90s and a cutter in the low 90s or like
a sinker in the low 90s
and all of those balls come out of your
hand looking the exact same way
you can just throw right down the middle
of the plate
and it doesn't matter your location
because you're essentially just
asking the batter to guess you know it's
like penalty kicks in soccer where
yeah the goalie just has to go ah i'm
feeling like this one's going
left yeah and it's it's incredible
um i don't know i i like it a lot i
think it's really cool
yeah so you know big props to baseball
for becoming
interesting again in just all the worst
ways that they wish they could avoid
um all right so that does it for this
episode no it doesn't
i also wanted to talk about a baseball
thing i didn't put it on the outline so
you were unaware of that
okay uh so in addition to
shohei otani setting the league on fire
uh jake degram
isn't getting as many headlines because
he's not also
tell him to hit 30 homers well he's not
also
tied for for the lead and dingers uh
but he's have he's in the middle of
maybe the best pitching season ever
uh so you know they're about midway
through the season
and uh his era is sitting at .69
uh which has never been done before
the the lowest era for a season ever
was .711
uh and that that was like 1937. that was
during the dead ball era
during the live ball era the lowest era
ever
was bob gibson uh at 1.123 in 1968 the
year of the pitcher
and pitchers were so dominant that year
they had to lower the mound
just to give batters a chance the next
season um
and so jake degram is i mean they're
midway through the season
if he keeps up his torrid pace which he
probably won't but like
unless he just falls off the table he
might break bob gibson's live ball error
record
uh and it's actually even more
impressive than that just because like
the current scoring environment is so
much
greater than it was back then um
so there's a stat for the nerds called
era plus
which is basically it's kind of like an
era z score
i think it's it's basically like how
many standard deviations better
is your era than than league average and
so bob gibson's era plus
in 1968 was 258
which is incredible like he prevented
people from scoring runs
uh at two basically 2.6 standard
deviations better than average which is
nasty
uh but they're scoring like twice as
many runs now as they were in 1968
so degrom's era plus is currently 551
which uh so five and a half standard
deviations
yeah oh my gosh which is
absolutely disgusting uh
simon yeah i mean if you if you're
looking at your data set and you see a
single value that's five standard
deviations off you check it you say oh
we might have entered the wrong number
yeah yeah yeah so some of the underlying
metrics
suggest that he's gotten a little bit
lucky so far this year so
there's there's a stat again for the
nerds like the
the rate at which hitters really get
their barrel on the bat
uh it's like hard hit balls and i mean
he's still way above average for that
stat but like
it's more in line with how his numbers
have looked the rest of his career
so he's probably gotten a little bit
lucky so far but even if he falls back
to earth a little bit over the back half
of the season
he he could still post an era below one
which would be outrageous
so like they very rarely
give pitchers league mvp awards uh
just because like yeah that's mostly
reserved for
for position players i think clayton
kershaw won one maybe like in 2014
but generally that goes to position
players because like pitchers have the
cy young that's basically the mvp award
for pitchers
uh but it's entirely possible that
shohei otani could win the al mvp
and degrom could win the nl mvp and just
have
pitchers sweep both mvp awards which i
don't think has ever been done before
but uh man it's a crazy year for
pitchers in baseball overall
uh and especially ohtani and degrom
and uh i think we largely have james to
thank for that
so yeah once again thank you to friend
of the show james ethan ball
look at us greg couple uh a couple
american blokes talking baseball
with the fourth of july coming up what a
patriotic episode eric i'm surprised
that you're not more into baseball
uh i'm impatient you know i don't watch
movies because they take too long
so the thing about baseball is the more
into baseball you get the less of it you
watch
because it's like it's just r
it it's a sport for nerds yeah uh
yeah like there's so much data it's so
granular because they have uh the st the
i think it's called statcast whatever
they have like high-speed cameras
watching everything
yeah everything can be quantified to
such granular detail
that uh i mean ever since billy bean
like the nerds have taken over the sport
and you know they're the purists that
are like ah but what does my eye test
tell me but i mean real
really it's it's the nerds that run the
show now
uh so yeah i mean if if you ever wanted
to make
if you ever wanted to watch a sport that
you could turn into like competitive
statistics it's baseball
yeah maybe i'll get into it when i'm
older
and like just develop a sports gambling
problem
[Laughter]
it's only a problem if you lose that's
true um
but no i mean it's the only sport where
i remember when i was a kid you'd go to
you'd go to a baseball game
and the old-timers would be in the
stands literally filling out their own
scorecards like you will see a person in
the stands
documenting the game in pencil and paper
like
that's the nerd level of that sport but
um
it's like what are you doing with that
are you going to submit that to the
league and say hey that should have been
a hit not an error like what are you
doing
um but anyway yeah um yeah
if you are celebrating the fourth of
july this weekend uh
you know everybody out there have fun uh
be careful
fireworks are dangerous you know don't
lose any digits
uh have fun uh you know a good way to
celebrate the fourth of july
greg what restocking your supplements
at bulksupplements.com that's
it's awesome so go to
bulksupplements.com the discount code is
sbs
pod to save five percent off your big
holiday order
uh that does it for this episode as
always thank you for listening and we'll
be back
soon thank you for listening to the
stronger by science podcast
if you enjoyed the podcast be sure to
sign up for our free newsletter to get
concise breakdowns of relevant research
as well as 28 free training programs for
all skill levels and all schedules
we hate spam just as much as you do so
we'll only email you when we have
something really interesting to share
with you
you can sign up for the free newsletter
at strongerbyscience.com
newsletter or just go to the stronger by
science homepage and click the free
programs button
at the top if you want to join in on the
stronger by science podcast conversation
be sure to check out our facebook group
and our subreddit the links for both are
provided in the description of today's
episode
finally please remember that we are not
medical doctors or registered dietitians
so before you make any changes to your
exercise or nutrition habits
be sure to check with a qualified health
care professional
once again thank you for listening and
we will be back soon with another
episode
of the stronger by science podcast
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you